you have to make 140 million dollars
plus the 5 million
production budget which means it's a 145
million dollar break even on a 5 million
movie
can you explain why a movie does not
make business sense it's such an
interesting question and an interesting
model when you talk about
the the the movie industry and the film
industry and
it
it's
the reason it's interesting is because
hollywood's always existed in this
bubble because uh it was always so
difficult to be able to create
entertainment and technology wasn't
democratized so no not a lot of people
could make entertainment and so
it whenever entertainment was made
especially film whenever a film was made
it was a very special rare thing and a
lot of that defied
the uh the rules of economics in the in
the rest of the world now it seems that
in a commoditized market and there's so
much content that
when you look at just the business of
filmmaking it uh it doesn't make a lot
of sense to a lot of people and if you
out if you go out and talk to a lot of
investors and the investors a lot of
times will tell you most times they'll
tell you that the economics of the
industry just doesn't make sense for
them where
you you you put up you put a lot of
money in especially say like a
independent film uh independent film
venture you put a lot of money in up
front uh you you don't see any return
for a long time uh there's no sort of
incubation model that you see out of
silicon valley or or even just a startup
business uh it it's it's a big crazy
roll of the dice you put a lot of money
in and you just hope and pray that a
bunch of people show up on the same
weekend and if they show up on the first
two weekends at least uh you maybe you
get your money back but if you if they
don't then you lose it all uh and it's
just a high risk um it's a high risk
venture especially in a commoditized
market where there's this hyper
competition and so it's uh it you know
if you look at
even other aspects i mean you think
other aspects of the way
normal business is done typically the
cost of the cost of production will
drive the retail cost of a of a product
for example and so if if you can make a
toyota for
ten thousand dollars then you can of of
hard cost manufacturing you could sell
it for i don't know twenty two thousand
dollars and there you have a margin in
there uh to make your money but if it if
it costs ninety thousand dollars to make
a maserati
then then you have to sell it for two
hundred thousand dollars in order to
have your margin you can't sell it for
twenty thousand dollars or else you're
going to lose money what and then that
just makes sense right of course that's
the way that's the way the world works
but when uh in filmmaking i could make a
five thousand dollar paranormal activity
and you could make a three hundred
million dollar avengers movie and
someone still goes pays the same twelve
dollars at the movie theater for the
product
and
that makes sense to us in the hollywood
bubble but for the rest of the world
that doesn't make a lot of sense and so
so now you're starting to see uh you're
starting to see a lot of conversation
around the variable pricing and maybe
blockbuster should be 50 movie tickets
and paranormal activity or indie films
should be two dollar tickets and maybe
we should scale ticket prices to the
cost of production uh trying to pull it
more in line with the way normal
business works and so uh it's
you know
when it just comes down to it
especially if you don't have any
pre-awareness of the market the venture
to most people is just very very risky
when you especially when you add in the
uh the cost of p a and
you know how much you have to saturate
the market with with marketing just to
get people there it takes the break even
in a really crazy way i think steven
soderbergh said a couple of years ago
that he predicted the the death of the
independent film market within five to
ten years because the cost of p a
was going through the roof at this in
this tremendous uh in this and it's just
tremendous rate so he said
when he's when you know 15 years ago
you would spend three million dollars to
make a independent film and then you
would put an equal amount in to for pna
uh with the which the the distributor
would you put an equal amount in for for
the pna and then ultimately you work out
your break even from that right so uh
so usually if you put three million
dollars production three million dollars
pna what happens is you have to recoup
uh 50 you recruit 50 cents on the dollar
for the p a and so you actually have to
make six million dollars to to make back
the three million dollars of the pna uh
because you split it the the distributor
splits it with the exhibitors right so
uh so that's how it would work out but
now stephen soderbergh says especially
with independent films everything's so
competitive and they're so oversaturated
and the market is so commoditized that
he says
you if you want to be a blip on the
radar
you have to spend at least 35 million
dollars of domestic pna 35 million
dollars of international p a
just so people know that you're out
there because there's so much stuff
hitting the market all the time
so uh so let's take a five million
dollar movie for example if you make a
movie for five million dollars and then
you spend
35 million domestic pna 35 million
dollars of international pna that's 70
million dollars of p a which means you
have to make 140 million dollars
to pay back
to recoup that right because you have to
split every dollar with the exhibitor
and you recoup 50 cents of the dollar so
you have to make 140 million dollars
plus the 5 million
production budget which means it's a 145
million dollar break even on a 5 million
movie
why does that matter this is why it
matters independent filmmakers require
uh and rely on going to investors and
saying will you give me your money so
that i can make my movie and so just
imagine the conversation of going to an
investor and saying i need you to give
me 5 million dollars of your money so i
can make my movie and all we need to do
is make 145 million dollars at the box
office and you get all your money you
get all your money back
does that make sense at all it really
doesn't it doesn't to most people now
some people have a you know they have an
appetite for risk and and and they you
know and they want their granddaughter
to be able to star in in a movie and so
they don't care to fund it and they do
it for other reasons vanity projects
things like that but more and more
investors now today it's like that just
doesn't make sense that's why studios
love to do
a hundred million dollar movies this is
where we've seen the death of the 20
million dollar film i think is
is because you think about like a 100
million dollar movie put a 100 million
dollar production budget
with a 100 million domestic pna 100
million dollars of international pna
that's 200 million dollars of p a you
recoup that 50 cents on the dollar which
means you have to make 400 million
dollars back plus the hundred dollar 100
million dollar production budget that's
a 500 million dollar break even on 100
million movie
so how many 100 million dollar movies
make 500 million dollars
as opposed to a 20 million dollar movie
making 250 million dollars
right it it uh now all of a sudden the
100 million dollar movie makes maybe
more economic sense than the 20 million
dollar movie because the pna is thrown
out all out of whack right so uh so you
know as filmmakers we look at films
through through the lens of of the art
and the the films of the the through the
lens of the story and what we want to
achieve and what we want to say
culturally but
we failed to put ourselves in the seat
of the investor and we and this is
something that i've learned i had to i'm
not a naturally inclined business person
uh you know some people are super
entrepreneurial and they get their mba
and things like that but i'm not a i'm
not a natural business person but the
more i was i i was talking with
investors the more they would and the
more they would tell me no the the uh i
would say why doesn't it make sense to
you
yeah and they would explain why this
doesn't make sense and the and when i
look at it from the
investor's point of view then i'm like
wow yeah that is kind of crazy and
that's why we're seeing
independent film investment dry up more
and more because just the economics of
the business model
just doesn't compute with the people
that have to fund the whole thing
and so you have to understand that
they're coming from it usually by and
large investors independent film
investors aren't filmmakers they're
business people right they're and
they've made their money in other other
sectors right so they're looking at at
everything through a completely
different frame than the filmmaker by
and large and
i think the more filmmakers can get in
tune with the economics
surrounding
a film and figure out how to
reorient the economics of the venture to
match the economics of a of a consumer
brand venture or a regular like a
silicon valley startup figure out how do
we how do we start to
have the film venture
look like one of those other things and
uh i think if we do that then we're
going to see maybe an uptick in the in
the amount of investment that now goes
in to independent films which would be
great for everybody right but it's just
going to take a paradigm shift
movies aren't as special as they used to
be uh because there's so many of them
and so uh we can't just rely on
movies being as magical in the eyes of
investors before we can't dazzle them
with a movie i don't think as much now
we have to we have to make sense to them
and and we have to be empathetic to the
seat that they sit in
is the film industry the only industry
where to graph out what you talked about
and really go down line by line it
doesn't make business sense or are there
other industries where that's very
similar well i think when
when you look at
what you typically look for is the
difference between a commoditized
business and a non-commoditized business
and these are big ten dollar words but
you know the difference is uh you know
commoditization is where
it is is a term where you're in a market
where where you're no longer unique and
uh because there's so much competition
there's there's uh you know hyper
uh competition and oversaturation that
has flooded the market
most businesses operate in commoditized
markets
but
businesses that operate outside of
commoditized markets by and large can
set their own rules and they can defy
those odds because what they're doing is
so special and so unique
they kind of get a pass
because they're you know they're
creating something that hardly anybody
else is creating
until other people start duplicating
that and they become commoditized as
well and there was a time when when the
smartphone was not commoditized and so
all of a sudden you know apple and steve
jobs they they could sort of set the
rules of the game of the economics of
the smartphone uh and it was up to them
not the market forces but
one now i think
smartphones have become commoditized in
such a way that you know that uh uh
that it's a different market than it was
you know 10 15 years ago or 12 years ago
however long smartphones have been out
right so uh so so i think you know when
you when you're looking for the
businesses that operate
outside of a normal paradigm you're
looking for the businesses that that
that are just super unique that uh that
don't have a lot of competition and when
you don't have a lot of competition
you're you know i'm from kentucky and
they and they call that being in the cat
bird seat it's you're in an advantageous
situation um and and entertainment used
to be that and filmmaking used to be
that because it was always too hard too
expensive too difficult uh to be able to
make a movie we we didn't have access to
the camera technology into the the
post-production technology we didn't
have access you know we had to shoot on
film and film super expensive we didn't
have the digital technology and we
definitely didn't have distribution i
mean the the the the biggest shift i
think for for filmmakers you know in in
you know since the invention of of the
of the the the talkie is uh the the
internet being a distribution uh uh
mechanism and because now the act the
the the ability to create and the
ability to to distribute has been
democratized to the filmmaker uh but
always before
people didn't have the technology to
create and even if you figured out how
to create you didn't know what to do
with it because you couldn't distribute
and so that that that that
that was that was a that was tough and
so the only people that could create
movies were you know five or six
companies in the entire world that had
the the technology and had the
infrastructure for distribution that
could do that so
anytime a movie would hit it would it
would be super special and it would it
would be an event and it would be
because we just didn't have a lot of
them coming out i mean think about think
about i remember when i was a kid uh e.t
was in the movie theater
for
over a year i believe all is around a
year right just in the theater the
theatrical run
now you know uh star wars was in there i
think 44 weeks uh the original star wars
movie you look at something like uh even
back to the future had like a 35-week
run in movie theaters now you look at
avengers in game which before the
re-release avatar was objectively the
the most successful film of all time
avengers in-game
that was in movie theaters for what
three months
and then it was pushed out there's too
much stuff being being pushed into the
system right there's too much stuff in
the pipeline i mean there's there's
there's uh you talk to show runners they
say 15 years ago there were seven places
that you could sell a one-hour drama now
there's 75 places you can sell a
one-hour drama right everybody's
everybody's making stuff because the
technology has become democratized and
so so it's it's
we the entertainment industry has
shifted
from
a non-commoditized very special magical
like dazzling
glittery thing
into
the same bucket as
smartphones and potato chips and coffee
shops and you know everything else that
that is commoditized which is now
forcing filmmakers and executives and
studios and and everybody that makes
this stuff now we have to re-learn and
uh uh what are the what are the rules of
the game what are the economics of the
game how do we how do we shift this to
better compete in a commoditized market
it's uh
i think i'm completely convinced that
the shift into a commoditized market is
i think for
for fans
it's the best thing that's ever happened
because we got as much content as we
could we have more content than we could
ever consume
with more movies we could ever watch
more tv shows that we could ever watch
more books we could ever read more games
we could ever play more songs we could
ever listen to we can't watch everything
on youtube we can't like there's more
tick tock videos than any one person
could ever consume ever which is great
for fans but the commoditized market i
think is the single biggest obstacle
facing filmmakers today the the the the
obstacle of access and creation has been
solved
right because we got cameras we have we
have we have you know if you've seen the
the the
uh the new iphone the iphone 13 that
that they announced like the camera
technology and that is absolutely
amazing right even iphone 12 absolutely
amazing what you can do with the camera
technology with that right uh but even
then beyond just the phones i mean you
can go get a red camera a red epic for
you know for a few thousand dollars uh
you know and you can rent a lens you
know for for you know several hundred
dollars over the weekend and you're able
to do that you didn't used to be able to
do that now you can and so uh so so that
has been solved uh access and creation
has been solved i think for for for uh
filmmakers distribution has been solved
for filmmakers we know now how to
get
our stuff to audiences we know how to
get it in front of people we know how to
build community we go direct to consumer
in about 35 different platforms right in
addition to the sort of the other
traditional platforms of you know
selling to the studios but even if you
want to go direct to consumer we have
the ability to do that the fact that i
can i can shoot a video right now and uh
uh hit a few buttons and upload it to
youtube and instantly it's in you know
six billion people's pockets is is it is
insane and crazy and awesome and
exciting so access has been solved
distribution has been solved
but now we've traded those problems in
for a new problem which is how do we
survive in a commoditized market how do
we
out punch
three million other things that are all
competing against each other somebody
said
to me recently
they said making a movie today is is
like being a needle in a haystack
because you just release it and there's
so much other stuff i don't actually
think it's being a needle in a haystack
i think releasing a movie in today's
market is like being a needle in a
needle stack
if you're an if you if you're in a
needle in a haystack at least you're
unique
but now when you release your horror
movie into the market that's awesome
that's such an amazing achievement right
but
a thousand other people are releasing
the horror movie
at the same time
and you're no longer unique and now you
have all this crazy competition and now
you have to figure out how to out punch
your way
not
you know out punch your way from the
from the the glut of horror movies but
also all the other movies and all the
other television shows and all the books
and then don't even get me started about
the tick tock videos in fortnight and
things like that that pull everybody's
competition or it pulls everybody's
eyeballs right and which could create
this hyper competition between all
platforms right so it's it's it's that
it's that obstacle of a commoditized
market that i think
needs to be the focus of filmmakers as
we go out of 2021 into 2022 and beyond
we need to figure out
again how to obviously you need to make
a good movie and and you need to tell a
great story you need to have rich
characters all that all the craft stuff
still applies i'm not talking about that
but now we have to shift the paradigm of
our minds and say what kind of model and
business model and ip model
can i
launch that
is not going to survive 1997 paramount
pictures hollywood because 1997 was
great but it was a long time ago that we
don't live in that market anymore
today's market is a commoditized market
and i need my plan and my model and my
approach to survive that
and that's a completely different
conversation
you